because i had had an experience in
relation to you years before where i had
made a firm decision that i would never
in my life
listen to anything this man has to say
uh based on a three-minute clip mind you
do you remember what it was that i said
that was so profoundly irritating
i mean there's many
can you tell me what can you tell me
what that was
of course
you were talking about the gender pay
gap um and this was a this was part of a
longer interview the you know the
interview that you had with kevin newman
and this was a clip three minute clip
you were talking about the gender pay
gap and you were saying that you know
paraphrasing here but that the reason
for most women is because most women are
agreeable most women don't negotiate etc
etc i i believe that was essentially
essentially giving
people
options as to why it could be that
there's this thing that exists or
doesn't exist and i didn't even finish
the clip i didn't even finish the
three-minute clip but based on the
things that another out of context clip
that i had seen before
and the way that i'd heard your name
being spoken of before in in the context
of the trans conversation that was
happening around that time 2018 right
exactly um
again i was watching this clip
and it's almost like i wasn't even
listening to what you were saying i had
already decided that i i don't like this
man because someone that i trust has
told me that i shouldn't like him so
therefore you know the decision is made
why do i even have to finish that video
right and it was just right and it was
just normal well you know we use
heuristics like that all the time you
know and it's easy to get caught up in
them because well you can't listen to
everyone
and so you kind of have to make a snap
judgment about almost everyone and and
this and the default is
you don't listen because there's like
seven billion people so obviously you're
not listening to most of them so you
don't need much of an excuse
and it's really easy for that to get and
i mean it's not like i haven't
experienced that like you know on my
podcast you know i invite people on
abigail schreier for example she wrote
uh i don't remember
her the name of her most recent book but
it's a investigation into the downside
of the
of the rush to make everything gender
fluid essentially
and i was terrified when when i had her
on i mean i wasn't rather irrelevant
irreversible damage yeah
you know i want to have andy noah on my
podcast but that also makes me nervous
too and you know because he's tired with
the fascist brush and
and then you get it's guilt by
association and that might have been
part of what you were feeling so
those so you think well you need a
simplifying heuristic and part of that
is well that most people aren't worth
listening to and he's definitely not
worth listening to and right
and then that can so easily become
politicized and once it is especially
when the political has become religious
it's really really hard
to overcome that
yeah and so it really is you know a lot
of the things that the radical left are
pointing out are in some sense universal
human failings
and so they have that truth about them i
mean because we could ask ourselves
um
given the implicit tendency for human
beings to have a pronounced in-group
preference
and the potential we have for violence
against out-group members
how do we all address our
proclivity to damn the foreigner
okay that's a really important question
i mean like i've got a good i've got a
good answer okay let me add the one the
one end to that and then the next thing
is well
we all have these proclivities how are
they exacerbated by by power and
privilege
right those are good questions but as
soon as we make it instantly racist well
then we can't even ask the damn
questions properly anymore so mick sorry
my joke is over now oh
i'm sorry i stomped all over your timely
jesus stomped all over my tiny little
joke
uh i was thinking about that question
earlier though uh if everyone has these
tendencies which they certainly do i've
noticed that if i have a guest on my
podcast and i think my audience is
fairly open-minded but then i'll have a
guest on that and they'll hate them
and they'll be like well you can't just
even if you don't agree with them maybe
and maybe they are wrong but like you
can't just cancel people because they
don't agree with you because you're
doing exactly the same thing that the
people you're complaining about well you
know and also maybe you're maybe your
stupid opinions aren't right they're
probably not right and like are you so
sure your life is going so much the way
you want it to go and you're such a
bloody paragon of virtue and the light
is shining out every orifice that
everything you think can say is correct
and everyone who disabuses you of your
notions is evil you're really so sure of
that are you
so you know you wander around and you
think god maybe i should listen to this
person because i'm such an ignorant
bastard and i'm so full of malevolence
and maybe they'll drop one thing on me
that won't make me like miserable and
doomed to hell and to drag everyone else
there too
that's
yeah well
you know i i
i felt something similar when i
finally leaned into listening to you
properly because what was interesting
even after that moment in 2018 watching
that three-minute clip deciding this man
is evil i want nothing to do with him
ever again and of course i didn't think
i would ever have anything to do yeah
look what happened
yeah right
um
people
in my especially people that were
not really connected to the digital
world a lot of my
a lot of older men in my life for
example and women in my life
would always tell me
to read your book it's honestly i people
would always say to me africa you will
really love this book i would have
friends of mine send me lectures i think
you're really going to like this and i
would just completely ignore it and in
my mind i'd be thinking
what am i what am i going to find what
am i supposed to like because again i
have this idea of you built up in my
head so i'm finding it very confusing
that people that know me very well are
telling me that there's something that
i'm going to like
right yeah what they are confusing but
again for years what the hell
years i ignored it
so when i started watching your lectures
late 2019 and last summer as well
in the beginning i could notice myself
listening to you
and finding
waiting
for a moment where i could say aha see
see right i i i knew i was right
and you know what i waited i went that
moment never came
that moment never came that was for me
right
and
that again so it's like there wasn't one
moment of being awake and then it's done
so many little tiny seemingly
insignificant moments where i'm just
sitting here by my sofa
just watching and listening observing
myself waiting you know for that
confirmation that i'm right and then it
never coming and then i have to deal
with that and then so
again my curiosity i finally allowed
myself to be curious again and now
jordan i can say you have been one of
the most influential people to me for so
many reasons reasons i couldn't even
mention right now um
but
to be able to have the conversations
that i do now publicly
you have
and i i i could have never
never imagined this ever in my entire
life this is
things like this don't just happen and
oh no
thank you just
thank you
thank you you got him
it's a pleasure
it's a rough pleasure but
um
you know did you knew what happened to
me with uh
marvel comics
yeah
that was something
it's really something to see yourself
portrayed you know i got accused of
being a nazi pretty much when all this
happened was really something because i
had been
teaching students
what we're talking about today about
these temptations that you faced and how
people as individuals get sucked into
that totalitarian hell
you know and then
so that was something for that to happen
such a reversal and then to have that
comic book come out well it was surreal
it was absolutely surreal to be
portrayed
because nazi wasn't enough right we had
to go right for the archetype itself
so i think we've raised about four
hundred thousand dollars for charity now
on the basis of that so that was a fun
reversal
but it was really shocking when i first
saw that i i just couldn't believe it i
was very ill at the time too
i thought this can't be real this has to
be photoshopped this cannot possibly be
happening it's so
completely beyond comprehension
and you know to come from the pen of one
of the foremost black intellectuals and
i i use the racial category only because
that's the categories that he's using to
operate with it
yeah
so
so life is really weird this is true
right
this is true
as this whole conversation illustrates